but you love TV growing up as a kid
right yeah I did TV oh my gosh that TV
was huge late night was huge you were
huge you know I mean while I was older
but uh right just I was more uh when I
was a kid like big into Letterman and
right right and uh Johnny Carson I
remember when I was really little just
staying up late watching yeah it's so
funny now that uh you know Johnny Carson
was uh the biggest television star
imaginable you can't even explain to
people anymore and he was such uh such a
iconic sort of uh you know in incredible
Mythic figure and so influential on so
many of us and
um I got this picture with him about a
year after he retired he but he he did
some event and I was there and there's a
picture of us together that's one of my
most treasured possessions yeah and um
my assistant who fills in for Sonos
working with me and he came into my my
study
because he was helping me set up a zoom
yeah and he was looking at the different
pictures I have on the wall of my study
and he was like oh who's that guy oh no
yeah and uh did he like sell you
insurance and it's not his fault he's
just really young yeah and but it's
incomprehensible to me that that someone
wouldn't know who Johnny Carson is you
know but that's uh yeah that's the way
it goes yeah it happens to all of us
that is why I mean even you know when I
was a kid and like my my like the way I
saw Johnny was like old Johnny and he
had been doing TV for so long at that
point and my parents knew Johnny as a
different Johnny you know and uh they
knew him from like probably I don't know
a younger era you're saying yeah yeah
yeah and uh uh yeah it's just uh you
know uh I I feel like lucky to have
caught a little bit of what's funny yeah
you just have I always think that the
stuff I saw as a kid is the most magical
to me yeah and there's so much I mean I
I think there's never been more good
comedy
uh available right at people's
fingertips
um than there is right now I think the
stuff that is being made
um by Young comedians is absolutely
there's there's so much brilliant stuff
out there
um and I'm Blown Away by what people are
achieving
but it'll never have the same magic for
me as stuff that I saw when I was a kid
yeah that made me laugh yeah when I was
just a kid in Brookline Massachusetts
sitting there you know watching TV that
has a power that nothing else can
replace yeah it's like the rock bands
you were listening to when you were 15
and 16 no music can ever fully reach
that level again you just get one shot
at getting into that portal totally then
what were you watching when you were a
kid that you really loved oh my gosh I I
mean I was besides late night I I was
big on sitcoms just you know I I I I
grew up sitting in front of a TV you
know uh uh just all the sitcoms I knew
when I knew the TV Guide which was
another thing uh back then just this
there used to be a magazine a book that
came out once a week that told you when
things were on yeah and it was more
important than the Bible it was the
Bible it was the Bible I also looked to
it for religious instructions
uh but yeah that was I mean I memorized
it you know every every night I knew
what was going to be on what time what
it was going up against you know I mean
and I I mostly sitcoms is what I'd watch
you know
I mean your era I know you're younger
than I am so you're watching like what
Silver Spoon Silver Spoon too close for
comfort too close for comfort yeah uh
Family Ties yeah too close for coming to
was a little before me but I did watch
that Family Ties uh new heart yeah uh
not the the original one but the the bed
and breakfast one uh um uh you know uh
Cosby Show uh
Golden Girls you know all of them you
know what's interesting is that every
show you just listed had laughter on it
yeah meaning it was either shot before a
live studio audience yeah it had and
it's so fascinating to me that there's a
whole kind of Comedy that young people
have grown up watching I'm thinking of
my kids
things that they really love and rightly
so they'll watch the office or they'll
watch Arrested Development
or they'll watch uh
uh Community or they'll watch you know
new girl all these shows that they'll
watch that aren't even on right now yeah
but
um
there's no laugh track there yeah and
it almost became
I wonder what they would think of these
shows where there's laughter now would
it seem odd to them yeah I mean that's
what I loved about them you know I know
isn't that crazy yeah I loved it too but
if I watched I mean I'm a huge uh Nathan
Fielder oh my gosh you know I I think
he's brilliant too and I love the
rehearsal and I love Nathan for you if
there was laughter on that it would
freak me out yeah yeah if there was if
there was laughter on Curb Your
Enthusiasm it would feel wrong to me
it's this this thing that I wonder about
a lot in comedy which is at some point
there was a period where it was just
unheard of that you would watch a comedy
on television without laughter yeah and
um and now uh we I think a lot of and I
think maybe it's for the good because
people are learning well I think I feel
like it feels more personal now and less
communal you know and I feel like back
then I I don't know it just felt like it
was you know you watch a show
and you you you feel like you're
watching it with a bunch of people and
then you go to school the next day and
you talk to your friends about that you
know it was all very kind of like I
don't know it felt like a a a a
community you know and I think the laugh
track kind of supported this feeling of
whereas now it's so intimate and and and
and nuanced and and I think that's great
you know it's just different but there
isn't that sense of like we're all in
this together yeah oh I remember uh
Happy Days was a huge show when I was a
kid and my best friend was Jake
Fleischer and there was uh an episode
where he was gonna this is not the
famous jump the shark episode but before
that there was an episode where he had
to do some
um stunt on his bicycle a motorcycle
bicycle the fonts had a bicycle
this was before he got really cool this
is his unicycle yeah he was a very fit
aerobically
uh in shape fawns no he had to do some
kind of jump on his motorcycle it was
like the first season of the show and
everyone in school was watching and I
was in maybe fourth grade fifth grade I
don't know what I was in but but
um I didn't get to see it but my friend
Jake Fleischer had seen it because my
parents wouldn't let me watch uh TV on a
school yeah and I the next day I ran to
Jake fleischer's house I remember as
fast as I could
to have him explain to me yeah is the
fans okay that's right and you know
today I would get on my computer first
of all I'd you know my parents they
can't control what I'm watching if I'm
streaming something on the computer who
knows you know this was back when well
back then like a a show airs and the you
you're never gonna see it again that's
it ever yeah or maybe it'll maybe it'll
be rerun yeah that's summer that's right
yeah but chances are you're not gonna or
you're gonna maybe see it in a rerun in
the spring maybe but uh it was um I ran
like a maniac like my life depended on
it and was pounding on Jake fleisch's
door like what happened he said he he
does get hurt and they they it's a
two-parter and he has to go to the
hospital for the next one because his
leg is hurt and I'm like wow I'll be
back
my dad used to we weren't allowed to
watch TV on a uh school night and if he
suspected that we were cheating because
we were always cheating
he would rush in we would hear him
coming because someone was on the
lookout and we would scatter turn off
the TV and Scatter but he would put his
hand on the TV set and this is back when
TV's had a little bit of an electrical
staticky charge yeah you could feel and
if he felt that shirt he was like get in
here
yeah no and uh it was it was terrifying
any TV if you couldn't watch TV on a
school night that was when all the good
shows were on well
um I got better at cheating we got
better at cheating but I missed out on
some really good stuff and and uh but
one of the advantages is that my father
was really into classic comedy so he
would make sure that I saw
um you know anytime like you're he took
me to a movie which was 10 from your
show of shows which was all of Caesar's
best sketches oh wow and I he took me to
the movie theater he took me to see
chaplain he took me to see Laurel and
Hardy he he made sure that I had this
great Foundation
um which is why I really fought hard for
uh our late night show to be shot in
black and white
and to mostly involve involve Prat Falls
uh but I I lost that one